les chefs des diplomaties russe et
américaine se sont rencontrés ce matin à
stockholm en marge de la réunion
annuelle de l'oms cee et dans un
contexte de vives tensions au sujet de
la crème washington est persuadé que la
russie envisage d'envahir le pays moscou
dément toutes velléités belliqueuses et
accuse en retour kiev de voir s'étendre
jusqu'à ses frontières qui dit espérer
un contact entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden dans les prochains jours les
détails sur place en suède de notre
envoyé spécial david khalifa
la réunion entre le chef de la
diplomatie américaine russe a duré une
trentaine de minutes ce qui en ressort
c'est qu'encore une fois saluer la
broche affirmé que la russie ne
souhaitait pas de conflit avec l'ukraine
et que pour sortir de cet état à de
crise il faut trouver un équilibre des
intérêts dans cette région anthony
blinken lui de son côté reste campé sur
ses positions le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a fait part de sa crainte
concernant l épreuve de force armée
russe à la frontière ukrainienne il
appelle moscou la mise en oeuvre des
accords de minsk sur le cessez-le-feu
mais note que les états unis sont pour
des relations solides avec elle a réussi
qu il est très important qu'il discute à
ce moment précis un juste après la
rencontre poutine maiden à genève c'est
la meilleure solution pour les deux pays
et pour le monde entier sergueï lavrov
lui a insisté également sur la
coopération entre les deux pays écouté
nos produits
il est nécessaire que la russie et les
etats unis adoptent une approche
responsable en réalisant l'importance de
nos deux pays pour la stabilité mondiale
et la sécurité dans la région euro
atlantique
il existe aussi des problèmes de nature
domestique je parle des problèmes
auxquels les diplomates russes aux états
unis font face nous avons été obligés de
mettre en place des conditions
comparables pour les diplomates
américains dans notre pays
nous sommes intéressés à unir nos forces
pour résoudre la crise ukrainienne nos
collègues américains ont dit à plusieurs
reprises qu'il voulait aider sans
détruire le format normandie et en
rétablissant le canal de dialogue
distincts qui existait sous la
précédente administration
quant au fait que tout le monde parle de
tension en europe aux frontières et en
particulier entre la russie et l'ukraine
vous connaissez très bien notre attitude
à cet égard comme l'a souligné le
président poutine nous ne souhaitons
aucun conflit mais si nos partenaires de
l'otan déclare que personne n'avait le
droit de dicter un pays souhaitant
adhérer à l'otan s'il pouvait ou non le
faire nous citerons le droit
international qui stipule que chaque
état a le droit de choisir comment il
poursuit ses intérêts légitimes dans le
domaine de la sécurité
cette réunion lavrov a nouvelle fois
exprimé son désarroi face au manque de
considération de l'otan vis-à-vis de
leurs propositions de paix lors de la
première réunion plénière de l'ouest à c
e il n'a pas manqué d'alerter également
sur le fait que l'europe revit une
triste période avec la construction d'un
nouveau mur à la frontière entre la
pologne et la biélorussie faisant
référence au mur de berlin en tout cas
cette première réunion plénière a
largement été centrée sur le conflit en
ukrainien l'objectif optimiser les
discussions pour trouver une solution
diplomatique et stopper les
confrontations à travers le dialogue